[Applause]
hello is what we've got me on this week
swipe hit meets the teenager behind a
fire safety app creative following the
Grenville tower disaster I investigate
the growing and tingly phenomenon of
ASMR and Simon's got a potential
knockout in our games review that's also
come for you after a quick look at some
of the tech news headlines that grabbed
our attention this week billionaire
entrepreneur Elon Musk has shot one of
his own Tesla cars into orbit on the
world's most powerful rocket after
launch
SpaceX's Falcon Heavy opened up to
reveal a mannequin in the driver's seat
listening to David Bowie the company
says the journey could last a billion
years and Elon Musk plans to go further
by the end of the year he wants to send
to paying passengers around the moon
mind-reading computers could be used to
help people analyze information and make
critical decisions in as little as 5
years we've been told researchers at the
University of Essex say one day sensors
on our heads in a CAF or an ear phone
could track our level of concentration
police surgeons and city traders might
be among the first to benefit from the
technology the UK's national
cybersecurity Center told us which
websites are most commonly spoofed by
criminals to try and scam British
citizens authorities removed more than
16 thousand pretend HM Revenue & Customs
websites last year and over 1,500 posing
as the government's information site gov
QK
five areas across the UK have been
selected to explore how drones could be
used to support their communities
Bradford London Preston Southampton and
the West Midlands will look at how drone
technology could be used for things like
boosting Wi-Fi helping find lost
children inspecting buildings and
delivering urgent medical supplies it's
part of the flying high challenge run by
the charity nester with government
agency innovate UK first up we're gonna
check in with kids he's been to meet a
school boy who's developed a fire safety
app following the devastating Granville
Tower fire in London sometimes
technology designed to keep us safe
comes about as a result of a tragedy
this one has already been getting the
attention of industry experts the fire
that swept through Grenfell tower
shattered a community and shocked the
world
the 114 year old boy from the capital
the disaster got him thinking about what
he could do to help I was completely
shocked by a was something that
unexpected it really made me think why
isn't technology being implemented - you
know try and assist in situations like
this since the age of 11 Barron korkmaz
has been experimenting with coding to
build games but for the past 7 months
he's been working on an app to help
people evacuate buildings in the event
of a fire is a mobile augmented-reality
evacuation and communication system and
how it works is basically it helps you
to evacuate a building by displaying
augmented reality tanks and guidance so
how about we give it a try first yeah
absolutely so we can see what's this
simulation showing us here so right now
as you can see wearing a smoke effect so
there's smoke around us and this is the
simulation so it's simulating as if this
whole office we've got in a big open
plan office here it's filling with smoke
yeah exactly
and now we can actually see the
augmented reality arrows and directional
tags to the exit as well as helping
guide people to the nearest exit Barun
hopes I'm Eric could also be used by the
emergency services to send an evacuate
command and that footage from the app
could be live streamed to firefighters
to assist with rescues
you can see we can see that data just
floating in with her despite this being
a prototype Behrens app picked up two
awards at the recent British invention
show and since then he's been getting
help from a firm that specializes in
indoor navigation I received an email
just as I was about to leave the office
saying augmented reality emergency exit
it captivated my attention and as I
started reading it the first thing I
read was Baran introducing himself as a
14 year old student who has built this
amazing technology that helps people you
know in emergency situations exit the
building with augmented reality and I
was blown away Behrens hoping to attract
the backing of a major tech firm so he
can trial his app later this year I hope
other people also see the vision I see
in America the vision that technology
mobile devices can really use to save
people in emergency situations
Kip Bradshaw sky news now have you heard
of ASMR type it into YouTube or
Instagram and you'll see just how many
videos pop up showing people making
repetitive and relaxing sounds and some
interesting and sometimes odd-looking
ways well this week I've been
investigating what this growing trend
with its massive following is all about
hello welcome to the sleep clinic I made
sure I was down on the schedule for this
evening if you're getting a tingling
feeling of peace from listening to those
sounds then ASMR is for you
it stands for autonomous sensory
meridian response and although not
everyone experiences the magical feeling
triggered by certain subtle sounds those
who do have a thriving online community
Emma
aka whispers read films herself making
soothing repetitive sounds with everyday
objects the videos have been watched
more than a hundred million times by
people craving ASMR trigger cells that
make them feel nice this is where the
magic is made in her tingle shed okay
this is the tingle [ __ ] I recognize it
from your videos now ASMR fans like to
watch and listen to videos like Emma's
because it helps them to relax or fall
asleep this is for kind of tucking you
in video do you mind if I just perch
myself on the side of your bed here one
of her videos is 9 hours long so fans
can let it play all nights with various
sounds that elicit an unmistakable
sensation in those who can feel it
ASMR is a physical sensation it's often
described as tingles like a tingly
feeling that usually starts in the top
of your head and it works its way down
your head and down your spine it just
sends you into this sort of pure
mindfulness state where you are
completely focused on whatever it is
that's giving you that feeling
we lined the Hudson with our tangents us
music artist Torres is one of those who
says she's always experienced ASMR
sensations and now incorporates triggers
into her music
just puts a book on a table and uses
their fingers to you know turn the pages
and that'll do it for me who's a huge
part of ASMR is repetition it's um you
know it can be hearing or the
combination of hearing and watching
somebody do something enough times to
where it sort of puts you in a state of
hypnosis and so that was the aim with
the music sometimes I use half of it
sometimes I use the whole thing
the autonomous sensory Meridian response
genre is fascinating scientists who've
begun studying it so people who don't
experience a smile they might not be
convinced that it's a real thing and
they don't really it's only through
things like YouTube and on my
communities and things like Reddit that
people have started to realize that
there's other people who experience this
this feeling and that they can access
content what YouTube videos that allow
them to simulate the screen if like me
though you've never experienced that
tingling feeling with certain sounds you
might be thinking it all looks a bit
strange and maybe a little bit naughty
but I hear that's a common misconception
yeah do people sometimes think it's a
sexual thing some people do if they
don't so we're so used to seeing a woman
come up close to a camera in a sexual
way in advertising and all you know in
the rest of the media but in ASMR we do
that because it's a connection thing and
we are coming up close to the camera
because our microphones are close to the
camera
Emma says she's found her purpose and if
the ASMR community is sleeping better
and feeling happier maybe we found an
online trend that really is good for us
albeit only some of us
if you're unaffected by those relaxing
sounds and you're wide awake and alert
with me right now it's time for a weekly
video games review here's Simon with his
pick of some of the latest releases he a
Sports UFC 3 for the Xbox one and
PlayStation 4 is the third in this
series I'm also pleased to tell you it
is the best mixed martial arts fighting
game that has ever been made the
presentation of visuals are second to
none and when you do get two fighters in
the Octagon and they start trading blows
it looks so brutal and it feels so good
to throw fists you actually may start to
feel like you're in the actual match
itself now one of the small problems it
does have is that the submission the
grappling game which is so important to
the sport is a little bit complicated if
you do give it time and you're patient
with it you will start to understand and
of course if you're a hardcore follower
of the sport you're going to enjoy this
more than a casual fan however you're
just like fighting games and you've
always enjoyed mixed martial arts this
is fantastic and it's absolutely worth
your time the city of Final Fantasy MT
which isn't exclusive to the PlayStation
4 it's one of the weirdest and quirkiest
fighting games you're ever gonna play
however once you get past all that it's
incredibly interesting if you are a
final fantasy fan you're gonna
absolutely love it because the fan
service here is second to none all your
favorite characters are in all your
stages all the environments everything
you could think that would come out of
the franchise has been put into the game
but if the gameplay itself which is
really gonna reel you in now he's a
three on three fighting game which means
it's three people going against three
people it's not just the case of trying
to attack someone without any thought
you have to build up a meter when that
meter gets to a certain point then you
want to unleash your attacks if you
don't do that in time that meat will
start to go down it's a bit like the
weakest link where you had to bank the
money if you don't bank that money you
can't do powerful attacks now again
obviously Final Fantasy fans are gonna
get more out of this but if you are a
fighting genre fan you should still
check it out because it's very very
different and because of that that's
really unique
America land of dreams land their way
Empire for the PlayStation 4 Xbox one
and PC is like a love letter to the
railroad tycoon games that were popular
around 10 to 15 years ago and that
basically means you are in charge of
your own railway network and you're
gonna make sure you build the tracks and
you're gonna make sure that your trains
run on time because if you don't your
customers aren't going to be happy and
your business may eventually go bankrupt
said in 19th century America that's all
you really do you have to run your
business and you just have to make sure
that it ticks over and you make a profit
it is a little bit light on content but
the real idea here is that you get so
into the simulation of it you're not too
worried about scenarios or missions or
achievements you just want to keep an
eye on profits and employees and all of
that and see where it goes so if you've
always been into that stuff
you'll love this however if you don't
like trains and you don't like managing
things you probably don't want this but
it's never for you to begin with that's
it for this week's show don't forget to
follow us on twitter at sky news swipe
and join us again next week bye bye
[Applause]
[Music]